[Musique]
jusqu'ici on a beaucoup étudié les
impacts du réchauffement climatique sur
les grandes espèces comme les ours
polaires symbole de l'arctique mais on a
beaucoup moins entendu parler des
petites bêtes
qu'en est il des impacts sur le petit
mammifère le plus abondant de l'article
le lemming une équipe de l'université
laval s'est penché sur la question
[Musique]
l'arctique canadien
c'est un des endroits qui se réchauffe
les plus rapidement sur la planète
[Musique]
bon nombre d'espèces c'est maintenant
connu subissent déjà les contrecoups de
ce réchauffement mais ce minuscule
rongeurs pourraient bien être une
victime silencieuse du dérèglement
climatique
matile de poirier aime les défis
cette doctorante s'est intéressé à la
vie du lemmings à une période de l'année
où il est le plus difficile à étudier
l'hiver ces animaux qui vivent sous la
neige à l'hiver donc aucune façon de
savoir ce qu'ils font à l'hiver autre
que d'aller sous la neige d'aller mettre
une caméra puis d'aller observer leur
comportement leur activité à ce moment
là
[Musique]
mais filmée dans le noir arctique n'est
pas une mince tâche
la chercheuse a donc fait appel à
l'équipe de génie électrique de
l'université laval pour concevoir des
condos à lemmings ces boîtes
d'observation sont munis d'une pile et
d'une caméra infrarouge pouvant résister
au froid pendant neuf mois
dans l'arctique les épisodes de pluie en
hiver sont de plus en plus fréquents la
chercheuse s'est donc demandé comment
une neige durcie par la pluie a affecté
le lemming comment se déplace-t-il dans
cet environnement et quels sont les
impacts sur sa reproduction
on s'est effectivement pas grand chose
sur l'écologie vernal des lemmings tous
conseils statuent un année où il ya un
cru de lemmings on va revenir à l'été
suivant plus il va y avoir un pic de
lemmings donc sans y avoir quelque chose
à l'hiver qui se produit tu mènes à
cette augmentation de population là
l'île bylot dans le routard tic canadien
c'est ici que l'équipe a installé ses
caméras le lemming connu pour fluctuer
en nombre selon des cycles qui varie
entre trois et quatre ans son abondance
détermine la santé de plusieurs autres
espèces
[Musique]
le renard arctique par exemple est à ce
point dépendant du rongeur que ses
effectifs diminuent quand le les mines
se fait rare
[Musique]
et cette dépendance est encore plus
marquée chez le harfang des neiges
legrand hibou va même jusqu'à déserté
l'île bylot pendant les années de faible
abondance du lemmings voici les
premières images captées par les caméras
infrarouges les rongeurs ont vite adopté
les boîtes d'observation on a vu des
lemmings qui rentrait dans la voix pour
s'alimenter sinon des lemmings qui se
nettoyaient aussi pendant l'hiver est
important qu'ils mettaient leur pelage
mais ce n'est pas ce qui a surpris la
chercheuse en plein coeur de l'hiver
elle a remarqué une activité accrue des
lemmings ce qui a déclenché une série de
vidéos
ce nombre de vidéos la augmenté au fil
de l'hiver puis l'année suivante on est
arrivé à l'été y avait un pic de
lemmings donc semblerait-il que le pic
est arrivé pendant l'hiver parce qu'on
voit sur nos caméras une augmentation
des vidéos pendant l'hiver mais qu'en
est il des conséquences d'une neige
durcie sur la reproduction du lemmings
pour le savoir les chercheurs ont
comparé la vitesse des déplacements du
rongeur dans différentes densités de
neige
[Musique]
les premiers résultats montrent que le
lemming mais beaucoup plus de temps à
creuser dans une neige dure le lemming
en creusant danse neige qui plus dur et
en utilisant ces aidants comme ça on
croit qu est sale augmente ses dépenses
énergétiques donc c'est pas vraiment bon
pour le lemming à l'hiver la conséquence
ultime de neige durcie est insidieuse
elle pourrait affecter le succès de la
reproduction hivernale et même
compromettre la survie des lemmings
on croit que la neige aurait le
potentiel de perturber les cycles
normaux de venir influencer l'amplitude
la périodicité des cycles de les mines
au cours des prochains hivers matile de
poirier s'attardera approuvé cette
importante hypothèse car aux yeux de la
chercheuse s'intéresser aux lemmings
c'est aussi mieux comprendre l'impact du
réchauffement du climat sur de plus
grandes espèces
des fois on oublie l'importance des
petites bêtes comme ceux qui sont
pourtant la base la chaîne alimentaire
en arctique s'y opposent de lemmings et
pau il n'y a pas de fondre sauvage en
arctique
[Musique]